مشروع
25 جنيه
جري وقود
عملناها هو اي حاجه
الموبايل
[موسيقى]
وجابتها
الكاميرا مثلا
[موسيقى]
مضاعفات
التركيه الاساسي
اليوم
واولاده
واخترعوا كويسين والعش
في الموضوع ده وهو المهرجانات
عشان نزرع الكبير
المباني سبع مليون دولار سبعه مليون
مجتمع المدن فقولنا جمعيه كونها دكتوره
سلمى بتاعتي اليوم
بدي حقيقه
الشباب
الانجليزي زياده يكون
بعد الزراعه 50 سنه عاش حوالي 30 سنه 40
سنه زراعه ويتوفق مثال ثاني ولايته اعلى
طبيب بتاع جراحه زراعه كبرينت
ودينا بعد ما كتبنا بالجوع
عشان نشجع الشباب على التدريب عليهم
تدريب علاء على المركز الليبي
في العالم
اريد اكبر
وقفت عليها ودعامه
[موسيقى]
وتعاوننا مع السكن 2014
يعني
[موسيقى]
اه هديه كان في 2014 هذه
الاقتصادي
ورجع ليفربول
المركز العالمي مركز تدريب العالمي في
السودان
البرنامج
بتلعب في الجوله في برنامج همم
برنامج الفائز وفي نفس الوقت يجي لنا
حصلنا على المواط
نه ندفع فلوس
مع عم محمد
صالح
حاليا حاليا
واجبنا اقتراف
تنظيم وظيفه من الدوله
[موسيقى]
ونحاول نخلص المبنى
التحدي
2019 هي كانت سنه
الصعوبات حقيقيه
على السودان
[موسيقى]
المباني
نبدا نعمل جراحاتنا نفتحها قبل كده
الشباب
[موسيقى]
يا عم بتتكلم ثمانيه مليون دولارات
نا موديلات جديده
مشوار طويل لكن
كثير
موجود
على اي جولدن ثانيه الصحه
نحن تواصلنا مع المركز
العربي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الزراعه
يعني
[موسيقى]
من الامارات
[تصفيق]
منتصر
انزل اعمل غير مقصود من وزاره الصحه
[تصفيق]